بسم الله ما شاء الله كل شجره في مزرعه
احمد لها قصه كما يقول رضا الله افضل منها
باذن الله التربه هذه طيبه باذن الله
ورثها عن ايباده واستغلها في زراعه
الفاكهه الاستوائيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اكثر من عشرين صنفا نجح في زراعتها حتى
الان ويامل غرس المزيد
نحن بحمليه غرس شجره الجديده في المزرعه
من ضمن الاشجار الموجوده السابقه الموجوده
معنا وهي من نوع شده التوت البكساني
وانتاجتها الحمد لله مثمره وشجره طيبه
شجعنا ان غرس نزيد من نفس الاشجار هذه
اما عبد الله الشنفري فبلغ مساحه مزرعته
نحو 30 الف متر مربع
زرعها والده قبل عقود باشجار استوائيه
متنوعه ابرزها الموز وجوز الهند المعروف
محليا بالنرجييل
يسعى هو وعامله الى انقاذ مزرعته من
الهلاك بعد ان اصاب اشجارها المرض
صارت مصدر قلق كبير للمزارعين لانها اذا
ما مكافحها سوف تقضي على شجره النارجيله
ولا هي تعتبر مصدر دخل اساسي للمزارعين
ورمز من رموز محافظه ظفار يصل معظم وانتاج
مزارع صلاله من الفواكه الموسميه
الاستوائيه الى هنا عشرات الاكشاك الخشبيه
الممتده لمئات الامتار على طول هذا الطريق
البحري شكلت وجهه مفضله للزوار والسياح
ترتاد خلود ونور القادمتان من مسقط اقصى
شمالي السلطنه منطقه اكشاك نارجيل في كل
زياره لهما لصلاله
كل سنه
يزخر سهل صلاله بتربه خصبه وتقسيم استوائي
فريد ظروف مناخيه جعلته مهيئه لزراعه
اصناف متنوعه من الفاكهه الاستوائيه
ويامل الاهالي ان يتعدى الاهتمامه بزراعه
الفاكهه المبادرات الفرديه ليصل الى
اهتمام حكومي يحقق الاكتفاء ويعزز منظومه
الامن الغذائي لسلطنه عمان سمير النمر
الجزيره بمحافظه ظفر